hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
the third section of the third chapter
of pirado's book
philosophy as a way of life is called
learning to die and in a good
bit of ancient western philosophy
thinking about and approaching trying to
understand and in some respect prepare
for
death lends a perspective
to philosophers that as i don't know is
often
lacking to so many others and this
doesn't just take place in ancient
philosophy you might think about
all the important ways in which this
affects things in medieval
thought and down to the the present
time now he talks about philosophy
as training for death and that's a
way of understanding philosophy
that comes to us from plato but also
from socrates plato's
teacher and as zado says um
here we go socrates death was the
radical event
which founded platonism now that's
that's an interesting thing to say
you might think about it as oh well his
teacher dies
plato goes off to try to figure out how
could this catastrophe happen okay
that's
there's all that there that's true and
that's been noted by other authors but
adult points out something else that's
quite important he says
the essence of platonism consists in the
affirmation
that the good is the ultimate cause
of all beings and you might think about
you know the symposium
and the republic and then you know how
that could get transposed
into other works as well what does it
really mean
so here he turns to a 4th century
neoplatonist
who says if all beings are beings only
by virtue of goodness
if if they participate in the good then
they must their
then the first must necessarily be a
good
which and here's the key point
transcends
being here is an eminent proof of this
souls of value
despise being for the sake of the good
whenever they voluntarily place
themselves in danger for their country
their their loved ones or for virtue
that is they
place their existence at risk they take
the chance of
non-being because there's something
that's greater
than even being or existence and that
is goodness and we can see
you know examples of this not just
within the plaintiffs movement but
within things that are being said
within the stoic movement and by people
admiring them like like for example
cicero
so this is a very important thing to
note
plato sees socrates dying
for the sake of virtue for the sake of
something that
transcends life transcends being
obviously could only be
you know actual existing if it is in
being but
is willing to go all the way to the end
so like he says
socrates exposed himself to death for
the sake of virtue he preferred to die
rather than renounce the demands of his
conscience thus preferring the good
above
being and thought and conscience above
the life of his body now ado says at
this point
this is nothing other than thee with an
italics right
so emphasizing this the
fundamental philosophical choice
why well because there's something
that's being placed in
complete perspective in in doing so now
in the platonic conception of this as he
notes it
death is the separation of the soul from
the body the body
dies decomposes the soul is separated
continues to live on
there's discussions of this and he
references for example the dialogue
the fado we see many other dialogues
talking about this
and one of the things that often gets
left out is well what happens
when we die and and here we could be
misled a little bit by plato's
myths or stories about you know
reincarnation and the soul
of some people who are really bad being
put into wolves or
things like that or going to punishments
because
what happens when we're when we're dying
when the soul is on its
own is you could say
at least for the philosopher the
possibility of
you know getting past individuation
and being enslaved to the passion so
he quotes this this this portion from
the phaedo
the death in question here is the
spiritual separation of the soul in the
body
separating the soul as much as possible
from the body accustoming it to gather
itself together from every part of the
body and concentrate itself
until it's completely independent and
have its dwelling so far as it can
both now in the future alone and by
itself freed from the
shackles of the body the body as a
prison is another way
that it's it's talked about in in the
phaedo right so
spiritual exercises are supposed to in
some way
alter the soul to prepare it
for separation uh he talks about this a
little bit
later as well concentration of thought
upon itself by means of meditation and
an inner dialogue
so he brings up the republic uh once
again in the context of the tyranny of
individual passions
and then he tells us about the dreams
the savage part of the soul does not
hesitate in thought
to try to have sex with its mother or
anyone else man god or animal
it is ready to commit any bloody crime
there is no food it would not eat
and in a word it does not stop short of
any madness or
shamelessness so you know you want to
try to leave that sort of thing behind
and you could also think about the
timaeus where the the
rational part of the soul is immortal
but the other parts of the soul are
actually
mortal and tied to the body
in the fado he describes a spiritual
exercise when a man does not go to sleep
before he's awakened his rational
faculty
and regaled it with excellent discourses
and investigations concentrating himself
on himself
having also appeased the appetite of
part and calm the erasable part
once he has calmed these two parts of
the soul and stimulated the third
in which reason resides it is then that
the soul best attains to truth so this
is something that one would do
each night as you know one gets ready to
go to sleep that would be part of the
spiritual
practice or exercise now it's
interesting because ado says
plato does things this way though the
whole platonus tradition is oriented
around this
but we could also look at other
traditions that
you know likewise use death as a way of
putting things into perspective
and don't have the sort of metaphysical
you could say commitments that
platonists have
so we could think about two that are
clearly materialist in the ancient
period
epicurus and the epicureans and the
stoics
he also mentions martin heidegger the
great existentialist and phenomenologist
a philosopher of the 20th century who
talks about being towards death as
something
central so he he tells us that um
here we go uh this has been taken up
in by such adversaries of platonism as
epicurus and heidegger
and then he tells us really the only
people to try to attempt to look at
death
are philosophers beneath all of their
diverse conceptions of death
one common virtue recurs again and again
lucidity being being straight about
things
understanding how things really are so
he says for the epicurean the thought of
death is the same
as the consciousness of the finite
nature of existence and it
is this which gives an infinite value to
every
moment each of life's moment surges
forth laden with incommensurable
value he then he talks about the stoics
in the apprenticeship of death the stoic
discovers the apprenticeship of
freedom then he says philosophy is still
a training
for death for a modern thinker such as
heidegger for him the authenticity
authenticity of existence
consists in the lucid anticipation of
death and it's up to each of us to
choose between
lucidity and diversion so so
a number of different approaches and he
could multiply this far beyond just
these four
you know of the platonus the epicurean
the
stoic and the heidigarian and he brings
up three
key concepts that are part of a
philosophical
orientation towards and preparation for
death one is realizing the
insignificance of
at least many human affairs the fact
that
a lot of the matters that we take
so seriously like you know giving the
speech that we're going to give and
having every single word
be right and then having everybody like
it and come up to us
death can take that away in an instant
and render it
meaningless what is meaningful what does
survive death what
does go on what what can we have
as a legacy that's what philosophy
orients us towards whether it be you
know the epicurean or the stoic thinking
about this or whether it be plato in the
symposium
talking about our desire for immortality
so there's that and then another key
aspect
is and this is an interesting thing to
say contempt for death now
why would philosophers be contemptuous
of this thing
or non-thing that is putting everything
into perspective
because as it turns out death is not as
bad
as so many people make it out to be and
by
realizing that by making that part of
your perspective
you do have a freedom that many other
people
lack then he talks about a universal
vision
characteristic of pure thought
right and that's something worth
bringing up
a little bit earlier he says that
training for death is a spiritual
exercise which consists in changing our
point of view
were to change from a vision of things
dominated by
individual passions that is emotions
desires affects
individual ones to a representation of
the world
governed by the universality
and objectivity of thought he says this
constitutes a conversion metastrophe
brought about with the totality of the
the soul and so that is part of this
universal vision this transformation
and then ado says something really quite
interesting he
points towards physics and physics we
typically think of as this university
discipline
that you know looks at basic particles
and might feed into
chemistry or something like that for the
ancients physics means
the study of the natural world and of
things that change
per se and so psychology would be part
of physics
astronomy would be part of physics all
sorts of things fit into physics
why were they so interested he says
physics itself can become
a spiritual exercise
when we look at it in relation to to to
death
and then he talks about it being
situated on three levels so he says in
the first place
physics can be a contemplative activity
has its end in itself providing joy and
serenity to the soul
liberating it from its day-to-day
worries this is what aristotle is doing
you know talking about the contemplative
life this is something that epicurus
has his people doing in the epicurean
garden where they're you know withdrawn
from politics but they do study the
natural world
he actually wrote along treaties on on
nature
and so that's a significant part of it
even the stoics say well we can look at
the universe as well
uh field of alexandria and plutarch also
bring this up and so there's all sorts
of ways we can we can think about this
but then we can go beyond that the
second level
is of what ado is calling a imaginative
overflight which causes human affairs to
be regarded as of little
importance here he brings up marcus
aurelius and his meditations and the
famous passage
that gets used for what we call the
exercise of the view from above suppose
you found yourself all of a sudden
raised up to the heavens and you're to
look down on human affairs and all their
motley diversity
you would hold them in contempt if you
were to see in the same glance how not
great is the number of beings of the
ether and heir living
around you so you know engaging in
physics in this sense also lends us
a set a certain perspective and marcus
does that not just
in terms of space you know go up and see
how little all the people
are they're like ants but also in terms
of time
and this is where we get back to death
think about your present right now
and the short amount of time from your
birth to
your inevitable death and then think
about the
you know eons of time before
and yet to come that helps to put things
into perspective
then there's this aspect of we can call
it transcending
individuality he says there's a third
degree
in the spiritual exercise of the vision
of totality and elevation of thought
to the level of universal thought
this is a way in which we can die to our
individuality
in so doing we don't lose everything
as he says we aced on the one hand to
the interiority of our consciousness
and on the other to the universality
of the thought of the all
and so he brings up a passage from
platinus and says
with platinus we now return to platonism
there is this possibility of detaching
ourselves
from our own individuality and
through spiritual exercises coming to
grasp
a more objective a more universal
whatever you want to call it thought the
good logos
and to find ourselves our true selves
within that rather than in this body
and its passions and all of the
determinate individual things about it
so
there's a lot of different ways in which
uh death gets used
to provide us with perspective and these
tie in directly
with spiritual exercises according to
pura ado
you